bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
dernier épisode de notre fil rouge de
l'été le dernier cours de l'année en fin
de l'été qui sera aussi le sera aussi un
petit court un peu plus détendu que
d'habitude parce qu'en réalité c'est pas
vraiment un cours c'est plus une
conférence que j'ai déjà donné à deux
reprises dans un cadre associatif donc
c'est passé par réellement un cours que
je vais vous proposer donc ça va être
une version light de ce qu'on fait
d'habitude d'habitude c'est quand même
chargé niveau contenu mais là
aujourd'hui on va se détendre un petit
peu c'est pour ça alors j'ai même pris
la petite tasse de café je l'appelle la
tasse de ma maturité voilà la tasse de
la maturité et donc on va on va
aujourd'hui parler de l'évolution des
cétacés avec une perspective africaine
alors vous le savez la perspective
africaine c'est quelque chose que sur
lequel j'insiste beaucoup dans mes cours
donné des exemples africains de fossiles
mais aussi donner des exemples de
chercheurs africains est la raison pour
laquelle je fais ça c'est tout
simplement pour donner de vous voulez
que les étudiants s'intéressent un peu
plus au contenu que je leur propose ça
leur permet de s'identifier un peu mieux
à ce que à ce que je leur montre et
puissent aller dès implique un peu plus
aussi au contenu que je leur montre et
c'est d'autant plus important que je
parle anglais avec un énorme accent
français
donc j'ai clairement pas l'air africain
moi même donc clairement poids susciter
leur attention il faut vraiment que je
leur montre que voilà je ggd intentions
bénéfique pour eux voilà faut vraiment
le faut vraiment que je suscite en fait
cette identité avec le court que je suis
en train de leur proposer parce qu ils
ne s'identifieront pas à moi voilà
clairement c'est ça l'idée donc da
perspectives africaines sur l'évolution
des cétacés
alors déjà l'afrique n'est pas
complètement à l'ouest quand il s'agit
évidemment de parler d'évolution des
cétacés il y à de grands sites à cétacés
en afrique notamment en afrique du sud
où on retrouve énormément de fossiles
baleine à bec c'est ce que vous voyez
ici sur la gauche il ya énormément de
fossiles de baleine à bec dû plier au
pléistocène enfin je crois que ces
familles hossein début pliocène on n'est
pas complètement sûr de la date en fait
parce que c'est des faux cils qui sont
retrouvés offshore donc en fait ils sont
repêchés par les filets qui traîne au
fond de l'eau sont repêchés par les
filets et du coup on n'a pas trop d'idée
du contexte géologique mais disons que
par leur de par leur anatomie de par
leur degré d'évolution entre guillemets
avec toutes les guillemets que ça
implique mais voilà de par leur anatomie
on arrive quand même à deviner qu'ils
ont vécu entre 5,10 millions d'années
voilà et puis on a surtout en afrique du
nord la vallée des baleines wadi al
harrington en egypte où là on retrouve
des basilosaurus des complets il ya des
faux cils magnifique partout donc c'est
l'image du milieu où la la c'est
absolument merveilleuse qui a été
retrouvée la s et d'une très très très
grande importance pour l'image générale
la grande image qu'on a de l'évolution
des baleines c'est basile autorités sont
d'une importance extrême est du coup
autant quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à l'évolution des cétacés
aux alentours de 2009 2010 j'aurais pas
pu dire que l'afrique était vraiment un
endroit très important dans l'évolution
des baleines autant maintenant on sait
que l'afrique a joué un rôle très très
important dans la dispersion notamment
des premiers protos cette idée
c'est olivier lambert de belgique du
musée de bruxelles qui a dessiné cette
cette image qui montre clairement que
l'afrique a été en fait un carrefour des
proto cette idée lors de leur migration
hors de leur bassin d'origine qui est le
bassin indopakistanais donc qui est là
où les cétacés ont évolué donc l'afrique
a été une zone clé de dispersion pour
ces protos et idées et leurs conquêtes
donc d'abord du vieux monde puis ensuite
du nouveau monde comme vous pouvez le
voir ici comme cette flèche vous
l'indiquent
et puisqu'on parle de route de migration
justement j'ai fait cette diapos là en
fait pour
illustrer ce qu'on sait de la migration
des baleines fossiles parce que c'est
une conférence que normalement je donne
à l'occasion de la cérémonie qui célèbre
le retour des baleines à bosse sur les
côtes sud africaines
donc les baleines à bosse migrent chaque
année entre les côtes sud africaines et
les côtes antarctique en fait et donc à
chaque fois qu'elle revienne en hiver en
afrique du sud donc aux alentours de
avril mai juin elles reviennent pour
l'hiver eh bien elles sont accueillies
avec une cérémonie et cette cérémonie a
plus des conférences à laquelle je
présente donc du coup je présente cette
diapos là qui est en fait ce qu'on sait
du registre fossile on va dire de la
migration des baleines à bosse les
fossiles de baleines à bosse en eux
mêmes
on en retrouve depuis 5 millions
d'années en afrique du sud donc c'est ce
qui est présenté ici c'est bon c'est ma
collègue roma lago wender qui les a
étudiées et sinon après on arrive à
suivre la migration des baleines à bosse
grâce à leurs parasites donc les
baleines à bosse on les appelle baleines
à bosse bon parce qu'elles ont une bosse
sur le dos elles ont une petite bosse
sur le dos quand elle plonge mais aussi
parce qu'elles ont des bosses sur les
sur la face est au dessus des yeux et
sur le menton et ses bosses en fait
elles sont couvertes de petits parasites
qu'on appelle les bacs et juifs qui
appartiennent à la famille des baleines
et ces parasites ont un registre fossile
et ce registre fossile beaucoup mieux
que les baleines elle-même que les
fossiles de baleines elle-même
permettent de suivre la mi les routes de
migration de ces baleines dans le
registre fossile donc ici en afrique du
sud le plus vieux de 2 c'est le plus
ancien de ses bananes parasites sceller
l aile à 164 1000 ans à peu près donc ça
veut dire que les l'afrique du sud était
déjà une route de migration pour ces
baleines ya 164 milan mais on retrouve
de façon très intéressante quelques unes
de ses balades en méditerranée or la
méditerranée n'est plus une voie de
migration pour les baleines à bosse
aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que
pendant une période en fait il a existé
une route de migration des baleines à
bosse jusqu'en méditerranée
peut-être
peut-être dû à des refroidissement
climatique qui du coup rendait les eaux
du nord beaucoup trop froide pour elle
même en été voilà donc maintenant
passons aux gros du sujet à savoir
l'évolution des cétacés puisque c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui donc
l'évolution des cétacés
si vous êtes un habitué de la chaîne
vous en avez déjà plein de fillon parce
que normalement vous avez déjà vu une
vidéo qui fait je sais plus deux ou
trois heures qui raconte vraiment
l'histoire mais de fond en comble de
l'évolution des cétacés
donc si vous l'avez jamais vu elle
existe sur cette chaîne il y a déjà un
cours d'évolution des cétacés niveau
master qui a été présenté sur cette
chaîne j'ai aussi représenter
l'évolution des cétacés dans mes cours
d'évolution des arts cieux dactyle et
j'ai reparlé de l'évolution des cétacés
aussi dans comme j'aurais voulu qu'on
m'explique
l'évolution des cétacés donc normalement
si vous êtes un habitué de la chaîne le
contenu que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui va être assez redondant mais
par contre il est présenté d'une façon
un peu différente de ce que je fais
habituellement donc peut-être que vous
allez le trouver intéressant alors moi
ce que j'aime bien faire
pour commencer cette cette conférence la
qui est essentielle est vraiment être
une conférence large public
c'est commencer par poser la question
mais d'où viennent les espèces marines
parce que quand on regarde justement les
espèces marines bas on voit les phoques
et les otaries par exemple sur la gauche
et puis bal et les phoques les otaries
on n'a pas beaucoup d'imagination avoir
pour se les représenter comme des chiens
qui savent nager
donc on se représente assez facilement
les ancêtres de ces bêtes là comme étant
des chiens qui vivaient sur la terre
ferme et qui se sont adaptés à la vie
marine
quand on regarde les manchots on n'a pas
de mal à y voir un oiseau et donc on
s'imagine bien quand même un oiseau qui
ressemblait vaguement à un oiseau marin
de type cormorans et goélands qui s'est
adapté à la vie marine a perdu la
capacité à voler et l'a échangé contre
la capacité à nager mais voilà on n'a
pas de mal à reconnaître dans les
otaries un mammifère carnivore et dans
les dents les manchots des oiseaux
marins qui se sont ensuite adaptées à la
vie marine
la nage et qui ont perdu leur capacité
de marcher pour les premiers et de volée
pour les second et ils l'ont échangée
contre une capacité plutôt un âge et
donc ça c'est assez facile par contre
quand on regarde les cétacés et
notamment quand on regarde les dauphins
ben je vous mets au défi de vous
imaginer à quoi ressemblait dans cette
de ce truc là ça ne se voit pas les les
dauphins et les baleines alors là en
plus je vous ai mis un dauphin ça reste
encore comment dire ça ressemble encore
un quelque chose d' humainement
envisageable mais quand vous voyez une
baleine bleue je veux dire imaginez à
quoi ressemblait l'ancêtre terrestre
d'une baleine bleue c'est au delà de
l'imagination en quoi le drc c'est de la
science fiction c'est limite
extraterrestre quoi donc à quoi
ressemblait un ancêtre de ces animaux là
bas c'est très dur à dire c'est très dur
à dire mais on a quand même quelques
petits indices qui nous permettent de
reconstituer l'histoire évolutive de ces
bêtes là et notamment le fait que les
dauphins et les baleines
hal est le fait que les dauphins et les
baleines ont des poils alors ça se voit
proches et tous mais chez les dauphins
au moins au stade embryonnaire il y a
des follicules pileux et même des fois
certains adultes retiennent c'est
follicules pileux et donc il ya des
adultes dauphin à moustache comme celui
là par exemple on sait que les baleines
à bosse pas puisque on en parlait les
baleines à bosse ce qui se cache là sur
leur petite bosse sous leur petite bosse
là ce sont des follicules pileux
puisqu'on les a déjà disséqué je veux
dire il ya une grande histoire de
massacre des baleines depuis des temps
immémoriaux une grande et longue et
triste histoire d des massacres de
baleines delà de la baleine riz et donc
on a eu l'occasion de disséquer des ces
bosses pour savoir ce qui se cachait
sous et ce qui se cache dessous ce qui
se cache sous la banane des baleines et
bien c'est un follicules pileux et on
sait aussi que les baleines sont obligés
de remonter à la surface pour respirer
et ça c'est pas anodin ça veut dire
qu'elles ont des poumons
bien qu'elles n'ont pas de branchies ce
ne sont donc pas des poissons alors
c'est quoi les baleines bas des animaux
qui ont des poumons des poils et qui
allaitent leurs petits ce sont des
mammifères
donc on est déjà à peu près sûr juste en
regardant la biologie de ces animaux
que ca que l'ancêtre de tout ce beau
monde là était un mammifère bon ça nous
avance pas beaucoup il ya 5000 espèces
de mammifères et si on regarde plus en
profondeur la biologie de ces cétacés
modernes et bien on constate par exemple
que les baleines franches ont
systématiquement un résidu d'os pelvien
à l'intérieur de leur corps alors ça ne
se voit pas à l'extérieur mais à
l'intérieur du corps on peut voir le
résidu d'os pelvien qui n'est même pas
attaché à la colonne vertébrale mais qui
est bien là et lui-même attaché à un
fémur un résidu de fémur et il ya même
certains dauphin qui naissent de façon
complètement c'est une mutation quoi
c'est pas c'est pas normal chez les
dauphins d'avoir ça mais il ya des
dauphins qui naissent aussi avec des
pattes arrière et quand on regarde
pendant ce temps là les pattes avant et
bien on constate une chose c'est que ses
pattes avant exactement le même le même
plan d'organisation que celui des autres
mammifères à savoir un os l'humérus 2 au
ras du sud n'a dé métacarpe et des
doigts avec un deux trois quatre cinq
doigts dont le premier doit est réduit
mais quand même
le premier et le dernier doit d'ailleurs
sont réduits chez ce dauphin là c'est
pas le cas de chez tous les cétacés vous
pouvez voir que ces sept baleines
franches par exemple à un deux trois
quatre cinq doigts normal mais voilà ils
ont ils ont cinq doit donc ils ont bien
un plan d'organisation qui est tout à
fait classique chez des mammifères
donc cela suggère aussi que c'est un que
ces cétacés avait des ancêtres
mammifères terrestres donc une baleine à
quatre pattes
voilà et maintenant la grande question
mais c'est à quoi ressemblait cette
baleine à quatre pattes
on est à peu près sûr désormais que que
l'ancêtre des baleines est un mammifère
terrestre
on le sait parce qu'ils avaient des
poumons le sais parce que les baleines
et les dauphins actuels peuvent à
l'occasion montré des résidus de leurs
pattes arrière donc maintenant à quoi
ressemble cet ancêtre à quatre pattes
des baleines donc évidemment cette image
est là pour vous suggérer que le
résultat si on imagine sans faire appel
à la paléontologie le résultat va
sembler grotesque donc la paléontologie
va être là justement pour vous sauver de
cette grossesse curie
et vous montrer à quoi ressemble elle
ancêtres des baleines l'adn est aussi
une source d'information non négligeable
dans cette histoire l'adn qui nous
montre que donc les cétacés les autos 7
donc les dauphins et les orques
mais les mysticètes aussi c'est à dire
les baleines les rorqual les baleines
franches et les autres grands cétacés
filtreurs appartiennent à un clac clac
qu'on aime les cétacés mais qui lui-même
appartient à un clac qui s'appelle les a
reçus au tactile ces arceaux dactyle ce
sont ce qu'on considère classiquement
comme les mammifères herbivores donc les
les camélidés que sont les chameaux et
dromadaires les cochons les ruminants
donc ça inclut les girafes les vaches
les chèvres les serres aussi etc et les
hippopotames avec en plus les
hippopotames comme étant plus proches
parents des cétacés que n'importe quel
autre que n'importe quel autre artiste
dactyle donc ça à la limite ça pourrait
même nous indiquer que l'ancêtre en
commun des hippopotames et des cétacés
devait être déjà plus ou moins semi
aquatique
c'est extrêmement débattu petit spoiler
c'est extrêmement débattu et il ya
beaucoup d' indices qui tendent à
montrer qu'en fait l'ancêtre des
hippopotames était 100% terrestre donc
on serait peut-être face à 1,4
convergence mais en tout cas déjà l'adn
nous donne une idée de ce à quoi
l'ancêtre en commun des cétacés devait
ressembler ça devait ressembler à
mammifères herbivores possiblement
semi-aquatique encore que la grande
question c'est est-ce qu'il ressemblait
plus à une vache à une girafe ou un
hippopotame ou un cochon ou un chameau
voilà mais ça on va le voir justement
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de la
paléontologie
parce que parce que si on s'arrête aux
données modernes
on ne peut pas répondre à cette question
alors on va aller explorer dans le temps
on va aller on va aller faire de la
paléontologie on va aller creuser donc
on va partir de notre présent actuel et
puis on va creuser creuser à travers les
millions d'années
explorez les des millions d'années en
allant en arrière dans le temps jusqu'à
remonter à l'ancêtre martiaux dactyle
des cétacés donc je vous propose en fait
un voyage dans le temps qui va nous
emmener à travers l'histoire évolutive
des baleines et des dauphins
donc on commence par les cétacés
d'aujourd'hui dont qui se regroupent en
deux grandes familles les odontocètes et
les mysticètes lesotho cet étang les
cétacés qui font de l'écholocation dont
qui utilise un sonar à l'opposé des
mysticètes qui n utilisent pas un sonar
mais sont les baleines filtres sont donc
les baleines avec des fans on essaie
fanon ce sont ce ne sont pas des dents
mais ce sont au contraire des
excroissances du palais donc ce sont des
cheveux en fait qui pousse sur le palais
c'est de la kératine donc c'est
littéralement comme des cheveux ou des
ongles c'est d'ailleurs plus rigide que
du cheveu donc on pourrait appeler ça
plutôt des ongles qui pousse sur le
palais donc quand vous touchez votre
palais avec votre langue
vous sentez des rugosités bas vous
imaginez si c'est rugosité devait se
mettre à pousser vers le bas eh bien ça
formeraient exactement ce que vous voyez
chez les baleines donc chez comme on l'a
déjà dit chez les cétacés modernes
il n'y a aucun indice de leur parenté
donc c'est pour ça que je mets trois
petites croix rouge en haut à gauche ici
on ne trouve aucun indice évident de
leur parenté au niveau 2 au niveau des
cétacés modernes donc leur anatomie ne
nous parle pas ne nous raconte pas leur
histoire évolutive plus que ça en tout
cas plus que ce que je vous ai déjà dit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon on
commence à creuser
on creuse on creuse et on remonte au
mieux ce n ya même pas l'oligocène
d'ailleurs il y à 30 millions d'années
on remonte jusqu'à l'oligocène et là
qu'est ce qu'on trouvait bien on trouve
que les eaux d'auto c'est télé
mysticètes il y à 30 millions d'années
étaient déjà séparés ils formaient déjà
deux groupes distincts mais qui était
beaucoup moins distingue qu'ils ne le
sont aujourd'hui
en effet les autos 7 comme les
mysticètes de l'époque avec des dents
donc c'est notamment surprenant pour les
mysticètes donc regarder itunes et us à
etios et us vous pouvez voir ac très
clairement des dangers
la chance de pouvoir photographier ce
spécimen moi même donc c'est une photo
que j'ai prise moi même celle là et là
vous voyez il a clairement des dents
mais en plus des dans itunes et us il
est intéressant parce que sur le palais
il à ces espèces de grandes de grandes
gouttières et vous voyez ici là ses
gouttières qui ont été peintes en rouge
ici pour être bien visibles ses
gouttières
on les retrouve chez les mysticètes
moderne et elles servent à envoyer du
sang et de denner vers les fans ont donc
elles servent à alimenter et à énerver
les fans ont donc ça veut dire que
itunes et us associé à la fois des dents
avec des fanaux et ça c'est très
intéressant d'un point de vue biologique
ça veut dire que les dents ont précédé
les fans on est que les dents devait
jouer le rôle des fanons avant que les
fans ont apparaissent un petit peu comme
on voit aujourd'hui chez le phoque
rabier le faux crabiers il a des dents
avec trois cuts speed comme ça et en
fait l'eau l'eau est filtrée
c'est un peu comme chez les cétacés
l'eau est filtrée par les trois cuts
spidey les particules sont retenus par
les dents à travers ces trois cuts speed
donc les dents devait avoir à peu près
le même rôle chez ses premiers
mysticètes tels que itunes et us pendant
ce temps là les ondes auto 7e qu'est ce
qu'ils ont eh bien ils ont déjà la
capacité de faire de l'écholocation on
le sait parce que leur oreille interne
qu'on a pu passer dans des scanners a pu
être étudiés on arrive à étudier l'os
qui contient l'oreille interne et 7 oz
préserve parfaitement la forme de la
cochlée et 7 cochlée à montre déjà tous
les signes d'adaptation à l'écholocation
à entendre les ultrasons donc ça veut
dire une cochlée qui est extrêmement
volumineuse avec un organe qu'on appelle
la mazière qui est extrêmement profonds
qui est une adaptation à l'audition des
ultrasons et en général une oreille qui
est aussi très isolée du crâne
donc le crâne ça évite que la résonance
du crâne viennent perturber le signal
est qu locatifs et pour le reste
eco venator état dauphin assez classique
excepté pour les dents et c'est là que
ça devient très intéressant c'est quand
quand on regarde les dents en fait les
dents déco venator elles sont
triangulaire avec des grosses pointes
dessus des grosses denticules dessus
donc un peu comme des tronçonneuses
triangulaire quoi et quand on regarde
les mysticètes donc à un proche parent
de itunes situe ce qui s'appelle corneau
dont et bien on constate que ce
mysticètes avait lui aussi des dents
triangulaire avec des grosses denticules
dessus grosse denticules qui devait
servir un peu comme les dents du phoque
ravier à filtrer l'eau et donc à jouer
le rôle des fans ont alors que les fans
on n'était pas encore complètement
développée donc corneau dont il avait
aussi des fans ont aidés dans mail et
d'en jouer le rôle principal et les fans
on était là plutôt en back up on va dire
et donc c'est que une fois que toutes
les deux les fans auront été
complètement développé que les dents
vont être totalement perdus chez ces
mysticètes encore qu'elles ne sont pas
totalement perdu chez les mysticètes
moderne puisque si vous regardez ce bébé
ce bébé baleine par exemple qui a été
disséqué et bien vous pouvez voir que
dans le maxillaire
même s'il n'ya pas de dents et bien il y
a les trous pour les dents qui sont là
donc les trous pour les racines des
dents sont là mais par contre les dents
ne pousse jamais et les trous se résorbe
de telle sorte qu'on ne les voit plus
chez l'adulte mais elles sont bien là
chez les petits donc ce qui unit en fait
c'est au d'auto cet essai mysticètes qui
vivait il ya 30 millions d'années
eh bien c'est la forme des dents et
c'est pour ça que je place la forme des
dents ici voilà cette forme de dents
très typique triangulaire avec des
denticules qui unissent les autos c'est
télé mysticètes désormais les autos
c'est télé mysticètes ne sont plus
complètement séparées ne sont plus
complètement différent il y à 30
millions d'années les deux partageaient
des traits en commun qu'ils avaient
certainement hérité d'un ancêtre en
commun plus anciens et nous allons donc
creusé en direction de 40 millions
d'années donc en direction de la fin de
l'éocène pour aller voir à quoi
ressemblait cette ancêtre en commun et
on tombe donc sur un groupe il y à 40
millions d'années qui s'appelle les arcs
et ossètes
arqués au seti essais archaeocètes qui
sont fièrement représenté ici par
basilosaurus donc basilosaurus qui nous
vient d'égypte donc ça y est on parle
enfin de cétacés africains donc
basilosaurus il a dit là déjà il faut
souligner il a tous les attributs du
cétacé vous voyez qu'il a un très long
corps on a des squelettes complets donc
ceci n'est pas de l'imagination il a un
très très long corps fuselé
hydrodynamique des nageoires des bras
qui lui servent de nageoires un long
museau qui lui servaient à attraper ses
proies comme les dauphins moderne il a
ici au bout de la queue quelques
vertèbres qui sont arrondis au lieu
d'être
la forme cylindrique de vertèbres
classique ce qui permettait de d'attache
l'attachement d'une queue en forme de
croissant qui est le elle aussi très
typique des cétacés dont qu'il avait il
avait une queue horizontale aplatit en
forme de croissant comme les cétacés
modernes
donc tout ça fait 2 basilosaurus un
cétacé au plus pur sens du terme
maintenant il ya des différences avec
les cétacés modernes et ses différences
elles sont notamment au niveau des
membres donc les bras jeu comme je
voulais dif agissent effectivement comme
des nageoires comme chez les dauphins
moderne mais le coude et mobiles
contrairement aux dauphins moderne et
surtout les jambes car quand on regarde
basilosaurus eh bien on constate que
basilosaurus avait des jambes donc ici
vous voyez ce petit ce petit zigouigouis
là en dessous du corps à l'arrière eh
bien il est constitué d'un fémur d'un
tibia et d'une fille bull a donc d'un
péroné
vous voyez ici les gars qui sont
fusionnés 12 ans tous ensemble avec ici
le talon est ici vous avez au moins
trois doigts qui sont préservés il y en
avait peut-être plus peut-être pas mais
en tout cas vous voyez qu'il ya au moins
trois doigts ici de préserver donc
basilosaurus était une baleine à quatre
pattes avec une patte arrière
suffisamment formés pour qu'elles soient
reconnaissables en tant que tel
contrairement à la patte arrière qu'on a
vu
tout à l'heure des des baleines franches
qu'ils n'avaient que un fémur
donc cette patte arrière elle permet de
dire que les arcs et aux sept étaient
des baleines à quatre pattes et ses
pattes arrière n'avait probablement de
jouer probablement pas de rôle clé dans
la biologie de basilosaurus mais le fait
le simple fait qu'elle soit là et bien
démontre que les arcs et aux sept sont
les descendants pas si lointain que ça
d'espèces qui étaient contre ont
complètement quadrupède et c'est pour ça
que ici je vous ai mis cette petite
empreinte de pas cette petite empreinte
de pas vous indique que le vous
indiquant fait la quadruple et 10 et
basilosaurus quand on regarde le crâne
de plus près on constate plusieurs
choses intéressantes la première c'est
la position de dunes et basilosaurus n'a
pas un évent comme les cétacés modernes
donc un nez qui est située tout au
sommet du crâne basilosaurus n'a pas non
plus année qui est ce qui est située
tout au sommet du museau donc tout au
bout du museau il a un nez qui est situé
en position intermédiaire entre la
position museau et la position et vend
donc sonné est en cours de migration
depuis la position museau ici au bout du
nez jusqu'à la position et vend ici au
dessus des yeux
donc il a un demi et vent voilà si on
peut dire les choses ainsi mais surtout
ce qui est intéressant avec basilosaurus
c'est ce sont les dans les dents de
basilosaurus son triangulaire avec des
énormes denticules dessus exactement
comme les auront 10 millions d'années
plus tard les autos c'est télé
mysticètes qui descendront de leurs
ancêtres en commun avec basilosaurus
donc basile 7 dans cette morphologie
dentaire vous le voyez elle fait le lien
entre les cétacés qu'il vivait il ya 30
millions d'années et les cétacés qu'il
vivait qui vivait il ya 40 millions
d'années qui eux avaient quatre pattes
donc voilà ce que je vous disais là sur
la position de l'évent basilosaurus
année qui est à moitié entre la position
au bout du museau et la position et vend
c'est à dire au dessus des yeux donc les
baleines à quatre pattes et là on en a
toute une diversité notamment en afrique
une diversité de basile autorités mais
aussi une fois une diversité de proto
cette idée c'est à dire des baleines qui
sont encore plus primitive que
basilosaurus du point de vue de la
morphologie des jambes
voyez ici par exemple carolina sais tu
ce qui a été découvert au sénégal et
carolina cetus voyait il avait des
jambes beaucoup plus développée que
celle de basilosaurus donc les pattes
arrières étaient beaucoup plus
développée et permettait certainement
une marche sur la terre ferme
ça aurait été un petit peu l'équivalent
de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui les les
otaries voilà donc est d'ailleurs vous
voyez que la reconstitution s'inspire
des otaries notamment voyez ces petits
pavillons auditifs ça c'est très typique
des otaries les pattes palmées ça aussi
c'est inspiré des otaries la queue par
contre elle est inspirée des dauphins
elle est à moitié entre une que normal
et une queue avec un croissant de lune
pour être tout à fait honnête on n'est
pas vraiment sûr de ce qui se passait à
cet endroit là c'est une licence
artistique j'ai envie de on a égypto
sais tu ce qui est un donc qui comme son
nom l'indiqué vient d'égypte et qui lui
a cassé marrant parce qu'il a été
retrouvé en fait dans une carrière où il
découpait les le calcaire en dalle est
du coup en fait le crâne que vous voyez
là il a été reconstitué à partir des
tranches qui ont été retrouvées dans
plusieurs dalles
donc en fait ils ont duré empiler les
dalles pour pouvoir reconstituer le
crâne et togo sais tu ce donc qui comme
son nom l'indiqué a été trouvé au togo
et qui est représenté par plusieurs
restes crânien et postgres nm dont cette
jolie mâchoire dont vous voyez encore et
toujours la morphologie dentaire
triangulaire et notamment les molaires
ici avec des denticules donc toujours
cette constante de la morphologie
dentaire qui permet de suivre
l'évolution de ces arcs et ossètes et de
les connecter au mysticètes et aux autos
7 qui vivait il ya 30 millions d'années
un des protos et idées les plus
intéressants à des archaeocètes à quatre
pattes les plus intéressants c'est
maiacetus maiacetus est très intéressant
parce que comme son nom l indique mme
aya veut dire mr cetus la baleine c'est
la balle et de mère pourquoi parce
qu'elle a un petit dans son antre donc
voilà la photo du fossile voilà le
dessin interprétatif et en bleu ici vous
voyez le bébé maiacetus dans le ventre
de sa mère près à naître la tête la
première et ça c'est absolument
fascinant parce que les cétacés modernes
ne naissent pas la tête la première
ils naissent les là que la première
pourquoi parce que comme ça là que sorti
en premier et permet une fois que la
tête est sortie de nager directement à
la surface alors que signer c'est la
tête la première
comme les mammifères terrestres
classiques comme les humains par exemple
où les vaches et les cochons les chiens
bref s'il n'essaie la tête la première
il aurait une chance de se noyer avant
d'avoir une chance de nager donc donc
c'est plus important de n'être là que la
première la tête en dernier comme ça ils
peuvent tout de suite
nager à la surface dès que la tête est
sortie
donc ça ça montre que maiacetus et les
proto cette idée donner naissance sur la
terre ferme
exactement comme les otaries le font
aujourd'hui et ça démontre bien du coup
que leurs pattes arrières étaient
capables de les amener sur le sol
puisque autre mandat ce petit bébé
maiacetus n'aurait pas pu l'être comme
ça la tête la première
donc là on s'approche on s'approche
beaucoup de ce à quoi devait ressembler
notre autres cétacés à quatre pattes
désormais on a vu nos cétacés ont quatre
pattes attend à quoi ressemblait leurs
ancêtres ça c'est la question devient ça
devient palpable maintenant donc on
saute on continue de creuser notre
colonne stratigraphique fictives
on remonte 10 millions d'années encore
en arrière on arrive il ya 50 millions
d'années nous sommes désormais à la
limite entre le paléocène eocène quoi on
est enfin paléocène début et aux scènes
et on trouve donc un do i du sein de
l'uci l'a 48 millions d'années mais bon
la simplification pour rendre les choses
plus simples je vais préférer dire ça
millions d'années ont un domicile et de
l'éocène inférieur il a 48 millions
d'années et un dos ils eussent est ce
qu'on a de plus proche de l'ancêtre en
commun de tous les cétacés
c'est le groupe frère de tous les autres
c'est assez bon alors déjà commençons
par décrire ce qui a des vies dans un
deuil ou à quatre pattes ça c'est assez
assez évident de le voir sur le
squelette que vous avez ici un do in us
est définitivement à l'animal qui était
terrestre vous voyez que les pattes
avant les pattes arrières sont aussi
longues et robuste les unes que les
autres donc c'est un animal qui savait
très bien se déplacer sur la terre ferme
ensuite vous avez l'image du crâne d'un
dolus ici vu du dessous donc là ce que
vous voyez c'est le palais d'un domine
us et donc vous pouvez voir qu'il a des
dents effectivement qui sont
triangulaire mais qui n'ont pas de
denticules néanmoins on sait qu'il ya un
proche parent d'ado y eut ce qui
s'appelle ces beaux quais russe et s'est
moqué russe lui il a des dents de lait
qui ressemble à s'y méprendre à celle de
d d archéo 7 et des autos cet ébéniste
i7 qui vivait il ya 30 millions d'années
vous voyez c'est dans triangulaire avec
des denticules mais pour tout le reste
c'est beau kéru se ressemblent à s'y
méprendre à un dos il use donc c'est
juste les dents de lait qui ressemble
énormément à celle de des archaeocètes
donc chez les espèces qui ressemble à un
do is on peut dire aussi qu'il y avait
des dents triangulaire et avec des
denticules et il faut pas sous-estimer
l'importance de ce caractère à ce niveau
là parce que l'un d'eux comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est un herbivore
il a des dents qui sont carrées enfin
qui ont une surface carrée et plates
relativement plate un douillet c'est un
herbivore ce n'est pas un carnivore donc
on peut pas vraiment invoqué la
convergence évolutive dans ce cas là un
do you say say boké russie l'ont pas
d'intérêt à avoir des dents triangulaire
et avec des denticules comme ça des
grosses dindes carnivores donc on peut
pas vraiment invoqué la convergence
évolutive pour expliquer la présence de
ce caractère sur les dents de lait de
ces animaux là
il y a probablement un lien
phylogénétique voilà c'est là où je veux
en venir c'est que là on est
probablement face à un lien un lien de
parenté quoi ensuite on regarde l'on
continue à regarder le dessous du crâne
d'un autobus mais on va plus vers
l'arrière du crâne et là on tombe sur
les bulletins panique alors les
bulletins panique c'est la caisse de
résonance qui est collée à votre oreille
interne et cette caisse de résonance
balcère d'amplificateurs notamment à
votre tympans elles servent
amplificateur avant que le son à et dans
votre oreille
donc ça sept bulletins panique c1 c'est
quelque chose qu'on rencontre chez
presque tous les mammifères mais chez la
plupart des mammifères qui vivait il ya
50 millions d'années on ne retrouve pas
de bulletin panique parce qu'elle était
cartilagineuse les mammifères primitives
les mammifères primitif parents avaient
généralement une bulle tympanique
cartilagineuse comme beaucoup de
mammifères
aujourd'hui longtemps encore c'est assez
rare finalement de rencontrer des
mammifères avec des bulletins panique
aussi fier et particulièrement il ya 50
millions d'années et c'est pourquoi chez
un dolus le fait qu'on ait rencontré
sept bulletins panique très très grosse
et très aussi fier très dense et bien ça
a tout de suite mis la puce à l'oreille
des chercheurs qui l'ont découvert et
qui ont dit mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on retrouve ces cétacés et chez les
archaeocètes donc les cétacés modernes
ont une bulletin panique qui est très
massif est très massive et très dense et
les arcs et ossètes ont aussi une
bulletin panique qui est massive et très
très dense au coeur donc sept bulletins
panique
c'est un caractère qui est continue chez
tous les cétacés y compris les cétacés
modernes et qui se retrouvent pendant 50
millions d'années d'histoire évolutive
jusqu'à là l'origine même des cétacés
parmi les espèces qui ressemblait à un
do in us et ça se voit très bien ici
donc ici c'est une vue à rayons x
une tranche qui a été fait à ce niveau
là en fait du crâne par rayons x et on
voit là bulletin panique ici regardez
l'épaisseur de la bulletin panique donc
la caisse
résonances elle l'a le sommet du crâne
est ici et là on voit donc la caisse de
résonance la bulletin panique et vous
voyez l'os de la bulle tympanique
l'épaisseur de cette hausse qui est
absolument gigantesque on voit aussi de
l'autre côté du crâne c'est c'est
vraiment un caractère très marqué et ça
chez les cétacés c'est une adaptation
pour l'audition dans l'eau c'est une
année une adaptation pour entendre sous
l'eau l'extrême densité de l'oreille
interne enfin des eaux qui contiennent
leur est interne des aussi culte de la
chaîne au ciculaire et de la bulletin
panique
ça permet en fait de séparer vraiment
l'acoustique du crâne de l'acoustique de
l'oreille
donc c'est une adaptation pour entendre
sous l'eau et donc voir ça chez un de
plus
c'est extrêmement significatif puisque
comme je vous le dis il ya 50 millions
d'années il ya quasiment aucun mammifère
qui est là qui as a key à une bulle
tympanique aussi fier et de toute façon
à part les cétacés
aucun n'a une bulletin panique avec des
eaux aussi épais et aussi dense
donc là on est vraiment sur ce qu'on
appellerait en anglais un smoking gun
guarné sur un sur une preuve extrêmement
robuste de la parenté d'un dolus avec
les cétacés et on a aussi même de tout
récemment en 2021 j'en parlerai dans un
palais aux news
on a une chercheuse française qui
s'appelle maeva orliac qui a étudié le
cerveau d'un deuil us et qui a remarqué
que les lobes golf actifs sont très très
allongée au lieu d'avoir des petits lobs
et olfactif en boule comme tous les
mammifères l'ont tous les mâles et
forment des petits lobs olfactif en
boule sedanaise sont très très allongée
exactement comme ceux les cétacés et ça
c'est pareil c'est aussi un caractère
partagé entre individus et des cétacés
les cétacés sont connus pour avoir un
sens de l'odorat qui a dégénéré donc les
lobes wolf actifs ont dégénéré aussi
sont devenus très fin au cadeau et
russes étaient déjà engagés dans cette
voie là du point de vue olfactif
évidemment vous n'avez pas pu pas pu ne
pas voir que 1,10 us et est un herbivore
puisque je voulais vip donc à dolus
quand on regarde ses dents on voit très
bien que c'est dans son carré et non pas
triangulaire
pointus comme chez les cétacés mangeurs
de poissons et de viandes moderne donc à
dolus était un herbivore
et là vous devez commencer à vous dire
mais attendez les herbivores
on en a parlé tout à l'heure des habits
bord il s'agissait des arts cieux
d'actes il les a reçus au tactile qui
sont tous des herbivores sauf les
cétacés dont si les cétacés ont un
ancêtre en commun avec ces herbivores ça
veut dire qu'à un moment il a dû y avoir
une transition entre une espèce
herbivore vers une espèce piscivores et
donc est ce que 1,10 us ne seraient pas
placés très très proche de cette
transition je dis pas que c'est la
transition mais ce cadeau youth ne
serait pas passée très très proche de
cette transition
et bien la réponse est probablement que
s'y passe quand on regarde le quand on
regarde l'os de la cheville d'un deuil
ou ce qu'on appelle l'astragale est donc
là si vous avez vu mes cours de paléo
mammalogie vous devez vous rappeler de
ça quand on regarde l'astragale dinde
aux innus c'est-à-dire l'os de la chine
est bien lost de la cheville d'un dolus
contrairement à la plupart des
mammifères à une double articulation il
ya une articulation avec la jambe d'un
côté mais il ya aussi une articulation
avec le pied alors que la plupart des
mammifères honte une articulation côté
jambes qui vous permet de bouger vos
pieds mais par contre votre cheville est
solidement accroché à votre pied il n'a
pas d'articulation avec le pied donc
votre pied est solidement ancré à votre
cheville
c'est pas le cas chez ado us à dolus à
une double articulation une avec la
jambe et une avec le pied et du coup un
deuil ou ça peut faire un ce double
mouvement de balancier qu'on retrouve
exactement chez les cochons les vaches
les serres et tous ces autres mammifères
qu'on appelle les a reçus au tactile
tous les arts cieux dactyle absolument
tous même l'hippopotame ont une double
articulation de l'astragale la fameuse
astragale à double poulies des arts sio
dactyle qui les caractérise
donc ça c'est un caractère dérivé d'un
ancêtre en commun qui est très très fort
chez les a reçus dactyle ai trouvé ça
chez 1 2
plus en plus de tout c'est de tous les
caractères qu'il partage avec les
cétacés va sa forme alia extrêmement
fort entre les cétacés et les a reçus au
tactile est une chose que je vous ai pas
dit parce qu'on n'a pas le temps de tout
couvrir
c'est qu'il ya il existe un autre
archaeocètes qui s'appelle il existe
deux archéos est en réalité qui
s'appelle pas qui c'est us et un autre
qui s'appelle rhodos et us et ses deux
arcs et ossètes ont eux aussi des
astragale à double poulies donc des
astragale à double articulation
exactement comme un do you c'est les
autres arsenal tient donc tout ensemble
tous considérés on a une on a en fait
une série de caractère à la fois
primitif et dérivés qui permettent de
connecter un do in us hausse est à la
fois aux cétacés et aux arts cieux
dactyle et on a une chaîne de caractères
et notamment les caractères des dents
les caractères des jambes et les
caractères des deux là bulletin panique
qui permettent de connecter tous les
maillons de cette chaîne en fait
ensemble les donc un dossier us avec les
a reçus au tactile un do in us avec les
arcs et ossètes et les arcs et ossètes
avec les autorités les mysticètes jusqu
aux cétacés modernes on a grâce à ces
caractères qu'on a suivi grâce à ses
fils rouges on peut désormais suivre
l'évolution des cétacés et reconstituer
l'évolution des cétacés jusqu'à leurs
ancêtres le plus ancien est ce qui lui
ressemble le plus à savoir à dolus donc
grâce aux squelettes dadis
on peut désormais dire que l'ancêtre des
cétacés devait ressembler à ça c'est à
dire un petit animal qui devait
ressembler un peu à un chevrotin ou un
petit cerf avec une dentition herbivores
avec des pâtes darciaux dactyle donc
avec notamment à quatre doigts comme
vous pouvez le voir les architectes ils
ont tous quatre doigts vous pouvez voir
que 1,10 us à quatre doigts au pied il
en a cinq omam et le premier
relativement réduit donc ça
fonctionnellement il ya quand même que
quatre doigts aux mains et il a 7
gala double poulies le dos et courbet
exactement comme les petits comme tous
les petits chevrotin et ses petits
ruminants qui vivent les petits
ruminants comme les daiker qui vivent
dans la forêt dans les forêts denses
dans les jungles justement un de youth
vivait sur le continent indo pakistanais
à une époque où le continent inde au
pakistan était un au moment où l'inde
était en collision avec l'asie donc il y
avait beaucoup de régions marécageuses
c'est un océan qui était en train de se
fermer donc il y avait beaucoup de
marécages de la guinée tout mais tout ça
est une forêt donc une jungle
extrêmement dense donc c'était un petit
animal qui était adaptée en fait à un
milieu qui était essentiellement
amphibie de forêt à la fois de forêt
très dense mais aussi de beaucoup de
marécages et de et de rivières et de et
de lagunes
donc c'est un animal qui vivait dans un
milieu qui était extrêmement amphibie en
fait et donc il s'est adapté à une vie
dans l'eau en partie dans l'eau ça se
voit donc sur son oreille oreilles qui
est adapté à l'audition sous l'eau et ça
se voit même aussi sur ses se voit sur
son cerveau je vous ai parlé de ses lobs
d'autres actifs qui ont commencé leur
dégénérescence et ça se voit aussi sur
les hauts cantons fait des coupes
histologiques sur les os donc si vous
coupez un numerus se sont plutôt là
d'ailleurs si on vous coupez l'humérus
dinde aux innus vous verrez que les eaux
d'un de youth sont très épais comme les
eaux des hippopotames ça permettait de
servir de ballast et de maintenir
l'animal au fond de l'eau donc il avait
toute une série d'adaptations comme ça
la vie aquatique et on pense que c'est
comme ça que quelques mammifères
herbivores de la famille des arceaux
d'activer poignée de mammifères
herbivores de la famille d un saut
dactyle quelque part à la frontière
entre le continent indien et le
continent asiatique en train de se
percuter ont commencé dans cette dans ce
marécage à devenir à devenir des espèces
amphibies et à s'adapter de plus en plus
à la vie aquatique de vous
par la même missive or et perdant au fil
des temps leurs jambes et développant la
queue avec cette forme de croissant se
sont adaptés à la vie aquatique et sont
devenus éventuellement des cétacés ont
fini par se transformer en ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les cétacés et donc
c'est ainsi voilà qu'on peut
reconstituer l'arbre phylogénétique des
ars yoda t-il avec désormais un dos lui
ce qui ressemble à un petit chevrotin
exactement comme les ruminants voilà qui
ressemble à un petit chevrotin b1
chevrotin qui vivaient dans l'eau et qui
aurait donné le départ en fait de
l'adaptation à la vie aquatique des
cétacés et ça se serait passé autour de
50 millions d'années et l'idée d'un
chevreuil aquatiques elle n'est pas si
bête que ça parce qu' il existe encore
aujourd'hui les chevrotins aquatique
donc dans l'est la jungle africaine
ce que vous voyez la vidéo en bas à
gauche eh bien c'est ce qu'on appelle le
chevrotin aquatique où les des
traductions récemment qui a progressé à
chevron a souri parce qu en anglais on
dit mousse dire mais ça on appelle ça un
chevreuil aquatiques ou alliés moss cus
éventuellement mais en tout cas ça
s'appelle prend 1 h vente à un cerf
souris mais bref
donc ce chevrotin aquatique il existe
réellement
il n'a rien à voir avec un do you saint
cela par contre c'est complètement de la
convergence évolutive c'est pas du tout
un fossile vivant non plus il appartient
à la famille des ruminants pas à la
famille des cétacés
mais il donne un analogue écologique à
ce à quoi devait ressembler un do in us
voilà et puis après l'idée darciaux
dactyle semi-aquatique devrait pas vous
choquer plus que ça on allait water bug
on met les hippopotames qui sont aussi
semi-aquatique donc c'est pas non plus
l'idée d'un herbivore aquatique elle
n'est pas non plus une nouvelle
normalement si vous avez une culture de
l'histoire naturelle et l'idée d'un
l'idée d'un herbivore qui se tape un
casse croûte de viande une fois de temps
en temps non plus devrait pas être trop
choquant si vous connaissez un peu la
biologie des cervidés notamment les
cervidés ne crache pas contre un peu de
viande quand ils en trouvent ils ne
crachent pas notamment compte du poisson
il ya des élans non c'est pas des
élancées des wapitis qu'on a vu nager
manger du poisson par exemple il ya les
girafes qui sont très connus pour manger
les eaux de leurs congénères ou d'autres
d'autres carcasse alors elles mangent
les oh certes pour s'alimenter en
phosphore pour pour alimenter la pousse
de leurs aussi conne mais il ya plus ou
moins de viande à ceux qui restent sûr
c'est sur ces carcasses donc c'est pas
toujours de l'os complètement sec c'est
exactement ce qu'il illustre hélas donc
et puis bah si vous connaissez les
vaches
voilà vous devez avoir rencontré des
vaches dans votre vie sachez que les
vaches quand elle passe par dessus le
nid d'un d'un oiseau qui niche au sol et
bien le sont pas contre bouffer les donc
la protéine animale n'est pas du tout
exclu complètement du menu chez les a
reçus active et d'ailleurs les
hippopotames sont pas en reste de ce
point de vue les des hippopotames sont
probablement les plus carnivore
parmi les as you dactyle les cochons
aussi d'ailleurs qui sont même
franchement niveau or dans le cas des
cochons qui sont bien connus pour ça
donc voilà le manger de manger de la
viande n'est pas enfin se nourrir de
protéines animales même de manière
générale c'est loin d'être un événement
rare parmi les a reçus au tactile donc
la transition que que les cétacés ont
subi depuis un régime herbivores dont
qui était celui d'ado y eut ce jusqu'à
un régime piscivores qui est celui des
cétacés d'une bonne partie des cétacés
modernes et qui était certainement celui
des protos cette idée de pas qui c'est
us par exemple eh bien c'est une
transition que qu'on n'a pas trop de mal
à s'imaginer en réalité voilà ce que je
vous ai donné comme je le disais c'est
la version de l'histoire où j'ai surtout
insisté sur les espèces qui étaient
d'une part que moi je pense être clé
dans l'évolution des cétacés et qui
d'autre part sont essentiellement
représentée par des représentants
africains
mais comme je les dis c'est loin d'être
l'histoire complète est évidemment vous
avez la version classique de l'histoire
qui est en train de défiler devant vos
yeux celle que vous verrez dans
quasiment tous les
reportage et tous les toutes les vidéos
youtube qui en parlait tous les articles
et tous les livres de vulgarisation qui
est extrêmement classique et qui est la
transition pas qui c'est us en bio c'est
us kiuchi c'est us ou remington au site
us des fois il a remplacé par titus vous
aurez les proto cette idée donc row 2
c'est us ou protos et us puis vous aurez
les deux rues dont il est laid basile
autorités et vous aurez enfin les
cétacés modernes
donc ça c'est le ski vous défilent
devant vos yeux c'est l'histoire
classique avec les taxons classique qui
vous seront montrées dans n'importe quel
autre contenu mais moi ce que je voulais
faire c'était vraiment vous montrer une
version alternative de l'histoire qui
met l'afrique
un peu plus au centre de cette histoire
alors évidemment je ne peux pas
réinventer l'histoire l'origine des
cétacés reste en inde au pakistan
le donc ça je ne peux pas le réinventer
je veux dire là
l'afrique a certes été un carrefour un
certain moment clé de l'évolution des
cétacés mais ça n'empêche que l'origine
décéda ses restes en inde au pakistan
pendant la collusion de la ddt avec le
continent asiatique qui a créé cet
environnement amphibie très favorable à
l'origine de taxons semi aquatique
voilà donc voila c'était tout pour
l'évolution des cétacés avec un point de
vue africain je vous dis à très bientôt
sur la chaîne
ciao